la central nuclear de sabor y allá se
encuentra en territorio ucraniano pero
lleva desde prácticamente el principio
del conflicto de rusia con ucrania en
manos de los rusos y lleva camino de
convertirse en el principal foco de
tensión de este conflicto de rusia con
ucrania el ministerio de defensa ruso ha
comunicado que ha vuelto a repeler otro
intento ucraniano de retomar esta planta
nuclear esta vez han sido unos 250
soldados ucranianos según los datos del
gobierno ruso los que han intentado
desembarcar en la zona a través de un
lago que hay cercano a la planta nuclear
hemos con segura que ha conseguido
repeler una vez más la intentona pero
desde kiev avisan de que la planta está
el peligro que hay un riesgo real de
fuga de radiación que además
recientemente aseguran desde el gobierno
ucraniano la planta ha sufrido
desconexiones de la red eléctrica lo
cual recordemos es un peligro puesto que
esta alimentación por vía eléctrica de
la planta es necesaria para mantener
refrigerados los reactores nucleares